angriff eines leoparden auf einen
menschen und zwar nicht irgendwo in
afrika sondern hier bei uns eine
raubkatze hinter einem zaun wir schauen
uns die bilder an aber das ist eben kein
zoo in afrika das ist hier ein
privatgrundstück mitten in deutschland
in sachsen anhalt in banken läuft dieser
leopard durch seinen privatgehege und
zwar vollkommen legal der nähe sind
gefährliche raubtiere in privatbesitz
unter auflagen erlaubt
ja wie lebensgefährlich die tiere aber
sind das musste jetzt ein foto model
jessica heidolf am eigenen leib erfahren
das tier hat sie angegriffen und ihr
gesicht zerfleischt wie es dazu kam wie
es ihr nach diesem angriff jetzt geht
das hat sie uns exklusiv erzählt wir
haben dabei
also kam ich diese doch noch operiert
ich hab wohl mal habe ich einige
verletzung hinten ob das die branche
keine ahnung an der zugebissen
er konnte ich gar nicht gucken wie saas
und baumstamm und ganze zeit war alles
gut und mit immer habe ich mich auf dem
fußboden wieder gesehen
dass schon gebissen es wird es
lokalisieren als männer wann
immer wieder in vancouver
habe ich auch geschrieben und wollte den
rücktritten und deine hände mit meine
normen so über kreuz wie man es halt
macht
ja dann der druck so kurz abgelassen
dass ich mich weg rollen konnte
zurück
aus dem käfig an
dann kam ja nur dass der hubschrauber
und dann irgendwann
[Musik]
was für eine tragische geschichte auch
weil wir die betroffene also das model
jessica die wir gerade gehört haben von
einem früheren termin kennen erst vor
ein paar wochen waren wir bei ihr und
haben sie zu einem ganz anderen thema
gesprochen jessica schmidt dem nicht
gleichzeitig auch für einen erotischen
kalender und zieht eichhörnchen auf ja
und für diese bilder reihe wollte sie
nun in einem privaten tierpark mit
leoparden auf fotos machen und dort ist
der unfall dann passiert jessica von uns
an dieser stelle gute besserung zu dir
ins krankenhaus
[Musik]